hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today I'm going to
be doing another one of my favorite gigs
where I review a website for somebody
and give them my feedback so today's one
comes from Brian and he's got a website
called master locators calm and he was
particularly concerned about conversions
and the sites call to action so let's go
check out the site and see what we can
do when we're looking at conversions
really want to think about do I
understand what you do do I understand
how it can help me and do I understand
what the next step isn't is that very
clear so let's look at this website so
look at companies called master locators
specializing and GPR and utility
locating so you know I'm not sure what
that is I don't know what GPR stands for
or utility located but it may be
something that people who are in your
industry with know a little bit more
about so you want to be careful about
putting short terms a GPR instead of
what it actually means but you're also
not really showing the value to your
customers so probably want to work a
little bit on that slogan in looking at
your you got three buckets and you've
got this thing that switches over here
so ground-penetrating radar okay so
that's what I guess GPR is utility
locating vacuum excavation
ground-penetrating radar can be used
identifying the ground tanks utilities
voice and other commodities beneath the
surface of the earth so this is such a
little bit confusing to me because what
I would assume somebody to come to the
site they would know what GPR utility
locating is if you're going to explain
it up here and then you say what it is
down here so instead of just putting the
explanation what i would do is talk
about the benefits that people get so
why would i use your services when would
this be helpful to me or not i'm
assuming we're dealing with i guess some
kind of commercial industrial types of
companies so you're very features
oriented instead of benefits oriented so
why should i use you versus other guys
doing the same thing looking underneath
we located on the ground utilities I'll
call the mass locator should be the
first critical safety stuff before
design acceleration construction
projects begin now this is actually
interesting this explains a little bit
more about what it is that you do but
it's buried further down on the page so
as an example I I built my own house and
we had to excavate and i'm not sure what
we had to do to look on the ground but
this makes a little bit more sense to me
now as to what you do so even somebody
like me who built his own house and had
to use probably somebody like you I
didn't even think this was a service for
me by looking at the top of this page so
if I were to lie on this page I'd be off
somewhere else because I wouldn't think
it's for me explaining it better down
here is something that you definitely
want to do a little bit higher up so
this makes a little bit more sense for
somebody coming to the site they can
understand what you do and is it for
them or not okay so that's going to be
critical the next thing is going to be
your call to action so this helps me
explain helps me understand what is it
you do I can get a little bit of a
better sense of how it benefits me the
next what would be the call I'm assuming
so call our offices for free
consultation so it's great that you have
this number down here what I would
probably do is put it higher don't know
if it's anywhere else put it everywhere
put it right here you got all this extra
space here put your phone number for
your email address you want to make that
super convenient and easy if you're
giving them a free estimate i think you
said free consultation or estimate
perfect put that up here make it really
visible make it easy for them to see how
they can get in touch with you as the
next step so if i'm clicking through in
these programs and I don't click down to
that bottom I want to make sure that i
can pick up the phone and call you
anytime some guys if they come and line
on your site and they see you know clear
benefits statement here you're talking
about underground locations look at
underground utility sorry and you talk
about design excavation and construction
projects if that's clearly clearly
explained up here I may just hit this
website to the phone number and call you
great for you potentially coming in the
door somebody doesn't want to kind of
waste their time a little bit longer
because they know that they want to get
in touch with you so you want to make
that super easy to understand what you
do and put your phone number and email
really visible for them to see next
thing I would try to have something
that's a little bit more visual so if
you talk about design excavation
construction projects put a picture in
here about what it is that you do beyond
just these buckets is a lot of text on
this page and not enough of a visual
representation at least for me so show
you guys in action or show them show
different design projects reservation or
construction so somebody who is hitting
this website we just want to read a lot
of texts can also quickly get a sense of
what it is that you do I like that you
have satisfied clients here this is
great you have some social proof to show
that people are really excited about
what you do but you don't show their
testimonios here i'm assuming i click
here i'll be able to see it you've been
around for 20 years it's great I would
have a picture of your client and your
testimonial right here on the homepage
and then make this more testimonials so
that somebody can quickly see right on
the homepage that you've got people who
really like what you're doing so that
again will help improve and improve your
conversions because you have proof that
I what you're doing works so let's see
what's next so if I you know I'm on this
homepage i think it's interesting i'm
going to click on request see what we
got here request underground utility
locating services master located is the
largest underground utility locating
firm on the east coast with offices so
this is great too so you've been around
for 20 years you're the largest
underground utility locating firm on the
east coast this should be on the
homepage to this explains a lot more but
what you do then those three buckets
that just confuse me i put this on the
homepage so this is great you have a
contact form most people probably won't
fill out a contact form but they'd
rather call or email in so you want to
make sure that your email is really
visible here as well which I don't
the email address for you anywhere on
here maybe if I could contact us but
again you want to make it super easy for
them to contact you so fill that in you
know most people probably what goes to
this forum but they'll call you or the
Sun Jian email here is he ever 100
number which is awesome too if someone
doesn't have to pay long distance then
you know better for them I'm pretty sure
on the homepage you don't show it let's
see let's go back yeah so here you have
the local number and then on this page
you have the 11 hundred number if you
have a 1-800 number put that everywhere
that's on your homepage that should be
in your top bar here call us 1-800
number easier something to pick up the
phone and give you a call so I
definitely make sure we're including
that everywhere next one I learn live
and what about your company so let's
let's look at your company in company
history so we've got seven 2003
acquisition okay so you bought known as
a handy associates before what I'd want
to do here is probably show a little bit
more so you don't have enough content on
here I probably show pictures of the
people if you can again smiling faces
people who have some experience a little
bit more about them you know the
construction industry very shady a lot
of characters that are hard to deal with
so if your professional and you show
your pictures and you show all the
background that you have and I see a
smiling guy that I think I can trust by
looking at his picture that will help
you with your conversions as well so
more content on here better explain your
history and your dedication to you know
quality service which it sounds like
you're all about and then also show the
people behind it you know why they
started it what they're doing now and
you know smiling pictures of them
ideally so definitely improve this page
a little bit more let's go look at the
testimonials we saw that from the
homepage how else kind of get to it
don't see it so let's go back to the
home page and look for some testimonials
so again this will help you to
conversions if I see that people are
happy with you and you've been doing it
for a long time so this this is good we
have some testimonials here we've got a
external link to the website this is
pretty good so we've got three you know
not a lot but okay I would definitely
put a picture of these people if you can
I don't know if you can find Carl the oz
bag page or Ryan Jones or these guys try
to find a picture if you can I'd also
try to break this up just a lot of text
and is bolded on at alexs so italics is
ok for quotes what I probably do is is
bold the key points that you want to
highlight so whatever the biggest
challenges you find that people are
people have in these projects and why
they end up Eileen hiring you so look
this is great they arrived on time
provide expert interaction with side
contracts and work hard to stick to the
time for a non-budget this is huge you
know a lot of the guys in the
construction industry are not on time
they don't stick to the time frame they
don't stick to the budget so I probably
unbolt all of this and bolt this because
this is the most important sentence in
this whole paragraph and is buried in
the middle and somebody probably won't
read it so you know this part is as
important you've worked at them with
nucleation clinical system areas unbolt
all of that both the key points and then
repeat that again for all of these take
the one sentence that means the most
bolt that humbled everything else and
again if you can put a picture of the
person that time but you're dealing with
let's see what else we've got up here so
you've got a blog let's check out the
blog
what is a utility tolerance zone how to
avoid Philadelphia stonework charges so
let's look at one of these blogs here
blogs are often a great way to the dr
search engine traffic i keep the website
fresh and updated so what is utility
tolerant zones you've got a super short
article here so if you're going to write
blog content I definitely mind having at
least 500 words for it to get picked up
in the search engine you you will have a
hard time getting the page like this
right unless it's super super
non-competitive the other thing you want
to think about is is blogging really the
best strategy for you you know like if
I'm hiring a company to see if I have
any utilities on the ground do I really
want to read their blog you know I know
when I was building my house when we're
in that excavation phase you care a lot
about it but afterwards you don't care
at all about it right your focus on the
next part of your project so i probably
wouldn't subscribe to your blog you know
it's not something that would be
something that i want to care about
afterwards right i don't really care too
much about what a utility tolerance zone
is as long as you can help me solve my
problem at the time now some of your
other customers may be different they
may really care what we have to say but
my sense is people would not care too
much about your blog and especially if
you're writing such short content you're
going to have a hard time getting this
ranked so what I would do instead of
trying to create blog post is create
landing pages so I try to think about
the different keywords that people would
search for and keywords that would help
drive traffic to your website no I'm
looking here you have master locators as
well in your your title tag which you
want to you know take that out because
you're probably going to rank for master
locators and try to put in the key words
that make the most sense for driving
targeted traffic so instead of again
instead of this blog and create targeted
landing pages each around different
keywords that you're trying to rank for
put in some great content you know at
least 500 words of content try to get
those pages rank and if you find that
you're having a hard time getting those
individual pages ranked then
what i would do is try to do some guest
blogging so find somebody who has a
related blog that covers this industry
in general offer the right of post for
them and then link back to your landing
pages to try to drive some traffic for
so it looks like you may already have
some here these might be some individual
landing pages I can quick look to
concrete scanning and imaging so
somebody is doing a search for concrete
scanning and imaging then hopefully your
page is showing up so this is a good
start again not enough contact here is
our content you want at least 500 words
you know I don't know if this is geared
enough towards your client and the
benefits that they're going to get so
maybe just examine the content a little
bit more to make it more better than
torrented it's a little more content
here it's great that you have the call
to action again I make this the 1-800
number instead of the local number and
if you find that this page still doesn't
ranking after you add more content then
you could do a guest blog post on a
different blog and drive traffic back to
this page here with the link so that
will help boost your SEO rankings so
hopefully that helps the quick breakdown
of this website I think it over all
looks very professional you know I've
done a good job with the design again in
this industry at least in the
construction industry that I've dealt
with and built in my house it's not very
professional the websites are really bad
so you're already ahead of the game here
but you can get even further ahead by
improving the benefits tape and
especially on this homepage making sure
you lock up this slogan a little bit
better totally change all this to talk
more about the benefits and clearly
explain what it is that you do and then
also have your 1 800 number and your
contact email very quick and easily
accessible for people and that should
hopefully help with your conversions so
thanks for the post there Brian for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give a thumbs up below
makes want to do more these videos for
you and if you have any comments about
master locators calm or if you have a
question about your own website or
business I'd love to hear from you if
you want to leave it in the comments
below I always read those
they make my day when I see them come in
so thank you and we'll see you on the
next episode